Might as well just grin and bear it.
The bear
selfie has arrived
with one bear
and Boulder, Colorado,
seemingly taking his cue from Madonna
Normally the city of Boulder,
open space and Mountain Park's trail cams
captured bears scratching
or eating or giving viewers a rear view.
But sometimes the bears
investigate the cameras
And out of 580
images captured by one trail cam.
About 400 or bear selfies.
So obviously the bear
was looking for the right angle.
Full on frontal side profile.
This one is giving me Lolita.
Noted one viewer I feel pretty.
Also pretty.
I feel pretty.
And witty and gay.
We don't even know if this bear is a girl
or a boy.
I can't say for sure.
It didn't take that.
That's exactly it.
And just like with humans selfies,
there were regex upon instead of a face
Wildlife experts never know
which critters will trigger
their motion activated cameras.
Be it a
wild turkey, a prairie dog,
a leaping fox, or a howling coyote.
And now we're howling over 400 bear
selfies.
Playing an actress,
trying to come out of hibernation.
All right, Mr.
DeMille, I'm ready for my costar.
Maybe not that close up
and quit baring your tongue.
Jeanne Moos, CNN,
New York.